this is one of the nice things about
talking about UFOs is it expands the
Overton window it expands our
understanding of what possibly could be
life it gets us to think I guess the
scientific Community to think when we go
to Mars when we go to these different
moons possibly of life
you know we're not looking at legged
organisms we're looking at some kind of
complexity
that uh
arises in resistance to the natural
world and uh there's a lot of
interesting resistance to the natural
world yeah so somehow there's a
rebellious process complex system going
on here and I don't know you know the
many ways it could take form and there's
a sense you know for aliens that as a
technology develops they take form more
and more in in as information
as something that can influence the
space of of ideas of the processing of
data itself so I just uh this idea of
embodiment that we humans so admire
physically visible perceivable
embodiment may be a very
inefficient thing right if you think
just about you know your area AI you
know we're we're trying to make smaller
and smaller and smaller uh circuitry
that is uh
basically
closer and closer to the physics of how
the universe operates right right down
at the level of I mean quantum computers
are basically write down about Quantum
information storage
so
fast forward ten thousand a hundred
thousand years maybe somebody found a
way to embody AI directly into the
physics of the universe right and it
doesn't require physical manifestation
it just it just sits in space-time it's
just a locally ordered space we're just
locally ordered space-time right
you know I mean people but maybe they
just they found a way to embody it there
they probably have to get really good at
not you know trampling on the ants the
the better your technology gets the
easier it is to accidentally like oops
right just destroy these simpleton
biological systems we constantly think
about whatever these things might be we
think that they are some sort of a
unified
Force well maybe they're not unified
maybe they are as disparate as you and I
are
and maybe what keeps them
from stomping all over the ants is each
other
right that they are in a self-tension
to prevent one or more of them from
running amok
oh yeah I mean that's kind of the
Anarchy of Nations that we have on Earth
so there's there's always
there's always going to be this um
there's a hierarchy this hierarchy
that's formed a greater and greater
intelligences right and they're all
probably also wondering wait what's
bigger than me exactly that's what I
always wonder is that maybe that they're
what keeps them in line is something
that is beyond them like what created
the universe I mean that in that that's
probably a question that bothers them
too